our next question is from Brynn also in
Pennsylvania how do you deal with
special items you bought or otherwise
gotten on vacation for example I have a
conch shell that I found on vacation and
it doesn't really add value to my life
but I'm having trouble getting rid of it
because it's one of those caught on
coats special or cool things you find on
the vacation another example is if you
go to Ireland and buy a wool sweater and
you don't really find yourself wearing
it that much but you want to keep it for
the novelty of saying you've got a wool
sweater in Ireland
how do you deal with these items if the
memory of a fun trip is associated with
them so Ryan I was thinking about the to
go back to the museum's for a second
because I think this is really
applicable to Bryn's question here she
saw about dealing with souvenirs I don't
think the real problem with museums is
like the curation they have that down
for me the real problem is the
consumerism the the exit through the
gift shop yeah I mean there's a whole
reason that Banksy made the movie exit
through the gift shop was to expose the
consumerism of the art world not just
the the money that's tied to art that's
a maybe a separate problem how there's
this over inflation of the price of art
these days but also the sort of the
trinket the trinket ization of of the
art world where literally a lot of
museums we go to you were forced to exit
through the gift shops because they know
that everyone at that museum wants to
prove that they were at the museum
people want to have a little trinket a
little token fastening that that Ramez
them maybe triggers a memory of the
museum or they can go to their friend be
like oh look I got this at the LACMA and
this is proof that I was at the LACMA
right and like that is why we exit
through the gift shop that's why they
have us exit through the gift shop like
they are playing to this to this need
that we have to it whether it's to
impress someone else or whether it's to
prove to ourself something there is
something affirming I'm not saying that
it's like a good way to affirm but what
museums know is that all that stuff in
the gift shop there is some type of
affirmation that a trinket will give
someone temporarily or or you know maybe
there's a trinket out there that someone
has they really really love I always
talk about my Stein my grandma got me I
really enjoy it I like having it if it
spontaneously combusted I wouldn't be
you'd be just fine with it yeah I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be upset about it
but I but I really do enjoy having it
but yes playing to that having to prove
ourselves that is exactly why you we
exit through the gift shop like when I
think about Brenda's question we always
talk about the why that's what we always
look at man why are we doing these
things right and you know with Brynn
situation I would look at why Bren why
are you feeling like you have to hold on
to that conch shell what they said was
is oh this is like a cool trinket that I
should have yeah is it is it is it you
should have it because you Brynn really
get a lot of value out of the conch
shell or is it because other people say
oh you should have a conch shell
um I mean when I like putting myself in
Brynn shoes I'm thinking about maybe if
like we had it some people over for
dinner on Sunday night and if I had a
conch shell sitting on my table be great
conversation starter well especially as
a minimalist cuz people would be like
we'll chop with a gong show just sitting
there but you know that I could be like
oh I went on this great vacation and and
let me let me tell you about this
amazing time that I had now when when we
tell stories like that or when we're
sharing an experience you know I would I
would I would challenge Brenda asked
themselves like are you sharing that
experience to impress are you sharing
that experience to be better are you
sharing that experience to make someone
jealous or are you legitimately sharing
this joy that you had with a vacation
the verbage that Bryn used with the
shell and use with the sweater it sounds
like it they're not hanging on to the
shell right - for them they're hanging
on for it to be cool they literally said
this is a
shrink that I'm supposed to hold on to
suppose to write I think I was -
according to whom right and I've got
this I've got this sweater from Ireland
and and look at this wool sweater you
know how Harlan's known for their wool
and well here it is I got the wool from
Ireland I know and I'm wearing it yeah
and Bren has got to ask themselves like
are you doing that for you or are you
doing that for other people again even
with the sweater it sounds like Bren
might be holding on to this sweater for
other people yeah so they'd so what
would it Brynn say um you know I have
this wool sweater that you're supposed
to have from Ireland that that that you
know proves that you were there and and
to your point man like who who says that
you're supposed to have it if it's Brynn
then great right like awesome you didn't
even then not great it's it's a slippery
slope also the supposed think so I don't
have a problem with either one of these
items um in fact if that's all you're
really struggling with is one conscious
shell and sweater cutter and that's what
you feel like you're supposed to have
like a problem they don't take a conch
shell and a sweater don't take up much
space people they're not the problem
they're symptoms of a greater problem as
you said that I'm supposed to have these
things because I want to impress other
people here that here's the the honest
truth you're not impressing anyone with
a wool sweater and if you are you you're
probably impressing the wrong types of
people the person who is impressed by
the conscious shell Wow well I would I
would just question who I was
associating with at that point this this
to me is a symptom of I know that well
maybe not a symptom but it's it's it's
like a parallel to social media how so
because this conch shell in this sweater
is something that Bren can have to be to
say hey look at me I've done a lot of
traveling and I got this stuff to prove
it and social media is this hey look at
me I'm having a blast that my life is
awesome and I've got all the pictures to
prove it and we've got to be careful
with getting back to the why we have to
be very careful with why we're doing
these things so Bryn why are you holding
on to the sweater because you think it's
cool there's a
there is a deeper meaning there is it
because it cool to you or is it because
it's cool to other people the same thing
with a conch-shell
it's a nice little trinket from vacation
is it because it's a nice little trinket
for you or is it something that you feel
like you need to show to other people
when when I think when we get to that
why when we when with these things
especially with souvenirs and it
translates over to social media when we
are talking about our experiences when
we're sharing our meaningful lives with
other people are we doing it in a
genuine way why are we sharing it are we
doing it with the intent to make someone
jealous or are we doing it because we're
we're including people not excluding
people
so she as a minimalist everything I own
serves a purpose or it brings me joy now
a sweater could certainly serve a
purpose
yeah keep you warm it can also bring you
joy you look great in a cardigan man
thank you the the conch shell could also
bring its product I serve a purpose but
it could bring you joy it's a beautiful
art piece that you that you just enjoy
maybe you never talk about it but you
just like the way it looks I have this
like glass joke art piece at at our home
and I don't talk to people about it but
like I just like the way it looks I
think it's beautiful and so it brings me
joy I don't you know I don't put like a
straw in it and drink from it or
anything but it so doesn't it doesn't
serve a purpose in that respect other
than I think aesthetically it is
beautiful
and you know what dude you think it's
beautiful yeah Rebecca thinks it's
beautiful uh-huh and you could give two
shits without all the thinks about it oh
yeah he's five I'm just I tell her
what's beautiful I'd know of what I was
really gonna say and you can give two
shits what other people think about it
yeah I mean what matters is is what you
and Rebecca have curated for your home
in that getting back to the why why do
you have that glass jug because you and
Becks really enjoy it it's a great art
piece and you really love what I didn't
say well yeah you love having a lot of
experience yeah you love the experience
of having a beautiful home in general
right I don't love the things themselves
right I love the experience that
the home gives to me but also the other
people who are rarely very rarely there
in my home and that's a good way of
looking at it too the jug adds to your
experience so maybe that's how Bren or
anyone else you know kind of struggling
with this this feeling of what I should
or shouldn't have what's cool to have
what's not cool to have you know what is
that thing
serving is it serving the experience or
is it serving something else I mean when
I think about I had this thought last
night about how oh I'm trying not to get
back into my mommy and daddy issues
because I don't want to go too much on a
tangent but a long story short I was
just going back to to having that that
perspective of you know my father is who
he is and he uses this this organization
as a tool to be you know who he to be a
version of who he already is to be a bad
parent so so to to look at that on a
broader scale last night I was like wait
a minute everything we do everything we
have these are all tools everything I
own is an extension of me every
experience I have is an extension of me
and I guess when it comes to owning you
know souvenirs we have to ask like how
is that tool serving a meaningful life
if that whether it's whether it's you
know a set of ideology whether it's a
set of beliefs or whether it is a
collection of souvenirs we have to ask
ourselves what are those tools serving
are they serving a meaningful life or
aren't they are they getting in the way
right exactly
yeah so I think curation when it comes
down to curating whether it's the
souvenirs or just the other things in
our life curation is really about is
curation is deliberate collecting and
there is nothing deliberate about
collecting everything right every time
we go to a new place to bring some new
trinket in so I think the first thing to
think about is stop bringing in
souvenirs going forward step number one
yeah dude I have been on it's funny I
have a section in my Gmail with travel
and then I've got like folders
underneath it but for every trip that
Mariah and I have taken for you know
putting
airline tickets filing receipts filing
reservation whatever it may be I've got
a folder that I can put all these emails
in and go to and I'm looking at Tokyo
Germany Europe I'm looking at all these
awesome places we have been yeah I don't
have one freaking souvenir for any of
them right and like I don't feel bad
about that at all we have plenty of
memories and yes and that's a word that
brin use the memory associated with them
of course the memories aren't in the
things that the memories are in us and
you do have some photos from those
places that can help you trigger the
memories but even then you don't feel
compelled to take your phone out and
snap a photo every single place you go
either right there yeah often a good
memory stick absolutely man you know
it's funny I when I was looking at the
that folder I felt Tokyo and I remember
Mariah talked me out this is this is why
I love having her in my life like she
talked me out of buying this it was like
a pagoda statue that it was only like
this big and it was like you know ten
but quit Valona ten bucks or something
and I was like man that is like a nice
cool little art piece and you know maybe
maybe I'll like it and she was like I
don't know like we're gonna put that in
the house and I'm like oh yeah you're
right like I don't really know where we
would put that and I you know I passed
on it I could have went back and got it
you know while I was there in Tokyo but
looking back on that situation like I
don't regret not getting that pagoda
statue like I am very content not having
a trinket that I can look at and be like
oh yeah that's from Tokyo well that's
helpful to having someone else in the
house and Bex and I have a rule that if
we both don't get value from something
that's in the house then we agree to not
bring it into the house yeah
now agreeing on that beforehand it's
harder what you have a house full of all
the stuff and you're like but no that's
mine really what I what I've agreed to
is I'm willing to let go of anything I'm
willing to walk away from anything and
I'm also willing to avoid bringing the
thing into the house if Beck's isn't
going to get some sort of value from it
as well now sometimes with Beck's it
could be she's gonna get so much value
from the thing that that that by-proxy
brings me value even if I'm not going to
use it you know she has this kettlebell
that she uses almost every day I don't I
don't use the kettlebell but she uses it
and like so if she gets immense value
from it so I'm like well of course I get
value by proxy then right but if there's
something else that I wanted to bring
into the house we're just gonna take up
space in this corner or whatever then
she has to agree that that is the best
use of that space we not just she has
degree we both have to agree that is the
best use of that space and sometimes
we'll say no I I don't think it is and
we have to be okay with that and it
allows us to bring far fewer things in
to the house now she she mentioned house
these or special items the conch shell
and the sweater are special special
items well it's only special Bren it's
only special if you say it's special
mm-hmm it's a sweater I mean when you
say something out loud like this yeah
but it's a special sweater this sweater
is so special it's like when I walk by I
was walking down maybe yeah go ahead I
was walking out Fairfax Avenue yesterday
and like there there's like some
sandwich board sign outside for this $18
rug and is like special special $18 rug
no it's not actually special just
because you say it's special right and
but at the same time it's only special
because you say it's special God the
word sounds the word special sounds
weird to me no it really does so so here
it may be maybe use the word precious
yeah
if something is too precious to me I try
to find a way to let it go oh yeah and
because I start question like why is
this so precious when it comes to
physical objects yes yeah physical goods
themselves if it's so precious that
means I'm giving it too much meaning I'm
making it too special you know this is
why I'm like I've decided recently did
not get a Tesla I don't know if I've
announced that you talked about on the
podcast yeah don't talk about it yet so
it's like NASA announcement I will not
be getting a Tesla breaking news
everything
just a little flash breaking yes you got
me Jordans on it for the YouTube video
did you see the one he did last week
with the lightning and the dog petting
no I haven't seen oh it's so good that's
all so you're petting a dog in last
week's YouTube audio of the check it out
but the reason another reason that I I
know I didn't mention on last week's
podcast about the Tesla is if I got a
Tesla and I didn't I you know saved for
the next you know two or three years and
was able to save up enough money to buy
a Tesla well then now I got a brand new
car mm-hmm that's gonna be too precious
for me I'm gonna hate when it gets
scratched I'm gonna be annoyed when it's
dirty I am it's good to be so precious
to me that it's going to affect my mood
it's gonna affect my day it's gonna
affect my time and attention that are
the two most important resources we have
and that is what you do to your point I
think that's what happens when things
become too precious so that that
ultimately is I mean that's kind of like
the already decided not to really invest
in it for the reasons that I said in
last week's podcast also because a car
is not an investment it's a depreciating
yes absolutely
yeah absolutely but the icing on the
cake for me I guess or like the the
final nail in the coffin for the tech
for the Tesla is that what a nail on the
icing
yeah nail on the icing that's alright
man is the is it is that that holding it
so precious yeah and it constantly being
on my mind like not wanting to have that
responsibility so I don't know in a
house right now like you know you and
I've been talking about doing some like
property investment type stuff and you
know the thought of being a landlord
yeah it might be a good investment but
dude that's gonna take up time and
attention yeah owning a new car is gonna
take up time and attention when
something is precious it will eat up
some of our time and attention and I
want to keep that as much of those
resources as possible or use those as
deliberately as possible yeah last week
we talked about the five most precious
resources that acronym we have steam st
e am skills and then time energy
attention and money and in buying a
house so I owned a house and they know
rental property and it requires all of
those less so of the skill but also but
my skills require the were required to
make the money in order to buy a house
right and thankfully Beck's is the one
who agreed to give up her resources
she's the one who manages the property
we also have a local property manager
there but it takes her time it takes her
energy it takes her attention
those three precious resources not the
physical goods themselves the house
itself isn't precious to me it's just a
house it's a it's a rental property
income and if the house were to burn
down tomorrow I have insurance and I'd
be okay I'd be just fine without it yeah
the two things four last things for
brand right before this we were doing
the YouTube pre-roll video that we do
every week we just do a quick pre-roll
thing and one of the questions that came
out the person said you know the thing I
struggle with with my collections is
always trying to complete the collection
I think we often treat collections as if
once we have the perfect collection it's
the scene from Fight Club where he's
like I almost have my apartment just
right like it's gonna complete us in
some way dude I would there's some kind
of like psychological thing there man
like for someone who has a collection
and they feel incomplete as a person
because they don't have the entire
collection leg there if they ever
completed that collection like god help
them because they're gonna have to move
on to another collection or they're
gonna be faced with why they're actually
feeling like they're not a complete
person you start to feel lost yeah I I
had that so you know with me and my OCD
I had all kinds of collections we've
talked about we did a collecting podcast
I think it was episode 118 and we in
there I talked about some of the things
I struggle with throughout my 20s like
DVD collections or Al Pacino memorabilia
like really random stupid things when I
go back but I would have a collection
and soon as I felt like either completed
the collection or I more than complete
because there's something you can't
complete the collection right having a
bun like Al Pacino memorabilia here like
there's an endless supply that's
I'm sure and so if you give an
overabundance I guess it's complete but
then yeah I didn't had to move on to
whatever the next thing was just cuz you
complete one thing you you you know as
an author I know this you finish one
book and all of a sudden it's like
alright start the next book yeah and so
you have to find a way to enjoy the
process of writing the book or those
things you have to enjoy the things not
the act of completing owning the things
because it doesn't become more precious
once you complete the collection now you
just have all this excess stuff you've
completed the excess I would encourage
anyone out there who you know is is
facing this where they've got a
collection of things but they don't have
the the complete collection and they
feel incomplete without it I would I
would you know challenge them to ask
themselves why do they feel incomplete
without the collection and I would even
bring that a step further and see if
they can maybe you know change the maybe
it's the internal dialogue or whatever
feeling it is that they are feeding into
with this collection right so really to
really try and work towards feeling
complete without having the complete
collection because that's power man like
being able to feel complete without
having a complete collection like that
is gonna that's gonna I imagine I mean
not even imagine like I firmly believe
that that right there sounds like a much
more meaningful life than oh I got to
make sure I have this this you know
entire complete collection yeah and and
the other thing too is if if there is
someone out there who's like oh man I
don't know I don't know you know I can't
get this last bit of this collection and
I don't know how I'm gonna get in I
don't feel complete ask yourself is
there something else going on deeper
inside why you don't feel complete
because getting the you know collecting
them all like that is going to be
temporary relief from the incompleteness
that you're feeling
yeah the definition of complete needs to
change for you you are already complete
you're breathing yeah you're alive
you're complete even if you're an empty
room the question then becomes what are
the things they're going to enhance my
experience of
yeah and guess what it's not the full
collection of micro machines from 1987
and so one last thing for Brin here
you're gonna have to let go of some
stuff because you're over complete right
now hmm and so this is sa it's coming
out on our website actually be out by
the time this podcast comes out it
already be on our website it's not just
about letting go this this one's called
let go the best you can yeah it's really
sure we look around our homes and see
everything we once wanted everything
that was supposed to make our lives
happy and better and complete and now
they're collecting dust unused the
exercise equipment the pet accessories
the stacks of magazines the Irish
sweater and the conch that you're that
you're holding on to and then there are
the things we could quote never discard
the items that hold wistful nostalgia
grandmas doilies dad's suit jacket mom's
jewelry that damn Irish sweater no you
aren't required to get rid of anything
but if you're stressed by the excess
then perhaps it's time to jettison
something mmm you needn't let go of
everything today
just let go the best you can yeah you
know the one more one more thing I want
to add to the British on you put that in
the show notes
it's a Bryn's question here is Bren
sounds like and this is not a judgment
this is just me dealing with the
information we have from this question
sure Bren sounds like they are trying to
get acceptance from other people Hey
look at me I've been Ireland hey I've
been to the beach I've been to this
Beach and I've got these things to prove
it in and you know someone might look at
that and go oh that's a really cool
sweater and then Bren feels good about
themselves like oh yes thank you it is a
nice sweater we all need acceptance in
some way anyone who is you know living
by themselves in the middle of nowhere
well they have Joe
to live without acceptance but they
still need it in in in in some way I'm
and I'm just I'm just you know trying to
really make sure that what I'm saying is
is uh makes sense in a general way yeah
we all knew the caveat right good yeah
so we all need some type of acceptance
the question is is Brynn what are you
are you gaining the right acceptance
with things so you might have this what
if Brent had this amazing collection of
this amazing collection of souvenirs and
great people looked at those souvenirs
and Brynn's got a really awesome
collection of souvenirs and brands got
that approval and that acceptance of
people telling them yes you've got an
amazing collection of souvenirs but is
that are those souvenirs is that really
serving a meaningful life I mean this is
really just my way of saying that we we
need acceptance we need people to to you
know support us in that way letting us
know that they approve of what we all
need approval in some way we just have
to make sure that we're searching for
the acceptance and the approval in a
meaningful way I think that when I think
about any of our friends like like dr.
green or Shawn or Jordan or Jessica or
our partners or my friend Nate Green's
gonna be in town this weekend and our
friend Sean mihalick is gonna be here
this weekend and we accept them not
because of any of the things that they
own and they accept us not because of
like oh wow you've I really like your
apartment or I like your car or yeah I
really like the way you dress that's the
wrong kind of acceptance exactly we want
to accept the person for who they are
not for what they augment their life
with because if you like just the facade
of the house but there are a bunch of
termites or it's just rotting inside or
it's just torn apart inside that's the
wrong kind of acceptance you wouldn't
buy a house that has a beautiful facade
but is rotting inside yeah and the same
thing is true with the the people that
we bring into our lives you don't expect
them to be perfect no of course not but
but we do
we do expect the sort of exterior to
match the interior well you know going
with that what I was talking about
earlier with these tools that we have
available to us in our lives and other
an extension I guess you know if
someone's out there and their friends
judge them or their acceptance is
reliant on the tools that they have in
their life well their friends might be
tools Brenna I'd love to send you a copy
of our book essential it's an essay
collection with a hundred and fifty
essays about intentional living it's
twelve different chapters twelve
different areas of intentional living in
one of those areas one of those chapters
deals with stuff there's quite a few
essays it might be the longest or second
longest chapter in there about how to
appropriately let go how to better deal
with the excess stuff that we have in
our lives so Sean I think you reach out
to her give her the audio book or the
book book or the eBook version of
essential essays by the minimalist and
we'd love to hear what y'all have to say
if you have a comment or a tip about
curating or collecting including advice
for any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail Oh at four zero six two one
nine seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips
you